HAVE MET.
THERE WAS A DO GETTHE FLY YEARSG
TO GET THE POSITION.
THERE ARE THE NUMBERS.
A BIG POWERPLAY PARTAGAIN T
A GREAT PUCK W AGAIN HERE THIS
AFTERNOON.
PHIL ROTH.
NOW OBEROV LOOKING FOR
>>PLAY BY THE LINEMAN.
THE PUCK SEEMS TO FIND MAYHEW AN
LINE.
GOES WIDE.
>> LOOKS TO MAKE THE HAS IT.
BECOME TO D. COMES BY BRAWN.
TO THE FIRST HEADS OFF TO OVECH
STEVE HART.
HE'LL COMEFRONT OF THAT GOAL
TENDER.
CARTER HART DID A GREAT JOB
BLOCKING WIDE.
LINES UP AND PLAYS.
HIT.
GOES RIGHT TO IT.
>> MAYHEW THEY GO, AND THEY
SCORE.
ATKINSON. T PUCK DOWN.
HE'S FIRED UP HERE.
GREAT JOB BY CAM.
HE COULD HAVE
IT FOR FIRST PERIOD ACTION.
ONLY THE SECOND TIMEMEIS THE END
OF THE SEVEN-GAME GOAL IS
DROPPED.
IT'S BEEN PRETTYBYPUCK'S RIGHT
HATHAWAY.
HE GETS IN THERE.
THE PUCK OVER THE NET.
DEFINITELY WAS MOVE IT
AHEAD.
BECOME TO PASS.
GOES WIDE TO HIS PLAYER, UP WER
PLAY.
>> THE DRIVE MOVES UP. IT OVER
HERE'SGOAL
TENDER, KEEP THEM AWAY FROM
THAT BLUE SPACE.
JUST LIKE
HE'S STILLBEAMING, AND THAT IS E
WAY, MAKING SEE THAT BOX, GOES
CLEARED ALL  FORWARD LINE
BY DEREK.
BIG-TIME TROUBLE.
THE SHOT DEFLECTION.
HAD TO GRAB HIGHER.
ELLER.PRESSURE OVER THERE, SN,DG
COMING ACROSS.
THE PUCK GOES THERE.
OLAV, JENSEN,  CHARGING UP.
AND DEFLECTED.
TO BRESARD.
THEY PLAY  TAKES THE SHOT.
MAKES IT IN.
AND THAT LEBRON.
HE'LL